à l'orée de ces débats je voudrais vous
dire que nous venons devant vous avec un
objectif simple construire un compromis
clair pour la retraite des Français je
le répète l'objectif du gouvernement et
de la première ministre c'est qualissus
de nos discussions nous puissions
trouver un compromis pour payer les
retraites des Français sans impôts en
plus ni retraite en moins alors je le
disais nous voilà devant vous cet
après-midi et c'est j'allais dire le
cycle naturel des lois financières après
l'Assemblée nationale vient le temps du
Sénat
et je veux vous dire
je sais qu'ici par de là les divergences
politiques on s'écoute je sais qu'ici
par de la les oppositions de fond on
débat je sais qu'ici par de la les
parcours de chacun on se respecte je
sais qu'ici il n'y a pas de ZAD il n'y a
que la République
et donc je serai tenté d'espérer
qu'après le vacarme et l'obstruction des
extrêmes s'ouvre à cet instant le temps
de la sagesse et de la raison
car je souhaite poser une question et
une seule
des senteurs de débats à l'Assemblée en
commission et dans l'hémicycle soit
davantage de temps que pour les réformes
précédentes qu'en est-il sorti de bon
pour les Français du point de vue de
ceux-là même qui s'arrogeait le monopole
de leur défense et qui ont tout fait
pour retarder les débats au fond chacun
apportera la réponse qu'il souhaite même
si je crois que les Français se sont
malheureusement fait leur avis et ne
nous ont pas attendu pour cela mais si
je pose cette question Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs ce n'est pas uniquement pour
dénoncer une nouvelle fois ce qui a pu
se passer si je pose cette question
c'est parce que c'est la seule qui
vaille d'être posée
et parce qu'elle résume à elle seule au
fond notre seul boussole celle qui doit
nous réunir l'intérêt général et celui
des Français et pour moi l'intérêt
général l'intérêt des Français il tient
en quatre points clairs d'abord pouvoir
payer sereinement les retraites de
bientôt 20 millions de retraités en
France ensuite ne pas faire perdre 1
euro de pouvoir d'achat aux Français et
donc exclure toute hausse d'impôts ou
toute baisse des pensions
troisième point équilibrer notre système
de retraite en travaillant donc
globalement un peu plus longtemps et
enfin prendre en compte la situation de
chacun pour que la réforme soit
équilibrée sur le plan budgétaire je
l'ai dit mais répartissent aussi
équitablement l'effort demandé aux
Français voilà la proche cohérente qui
est la nôtre et que nous soumettons à
votre examen voilà le cadre qui est le
nôtre et dont nous ne dérogerons pas
mais au sein duquel nous sommes ouverts
au compromis voilà ce qui nous semble
être des conditions raisonnables pour
œuvrer ensemble au service de l'intérêt
général et en l'espèce l'intérêt général
cela veut dire permettre à chaque
Français le temps venu de pouvoir
compter sereinement sur la retraite à
laquelle il a droit ni plus ni moins
voilà ce qui est en jeu préserver nos
retraites non pas par dogme ou par
réflexe mais par bon sens une vie de
travail à la fin on doit en voir les
fruits et le fruit d'une ville de d'une
ville de travail pour l'immense majorité
des Français c'est leur pension de
retraite qui leur permettent de financer
leur mode de vie auquel ils n'ont aucune
envie de renoncer au fond c'est cela la
classe moyenne tous les Français qui
n'ont que leur travail pour vivre cette
classe moyenne qui a trop souvent le
sentiment de travailler pour d'autres
qui eux font le choix de ne pas
travailler si on ajoute à cela le fait
de travailler dur pour une retraite qui
en plus diminuerait alors ces Français
perdront définitivement foi en l'action
publique alors c'est pour eux que nous
agissons c'est pour eux que nous sommes
engagés dans cette bataille c'est pour
eux que nous vous présentons ce texte et
c'est pour eux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que je souhaite lancer un
appel loin des polémiques les polémiques
j'adresse un appel engageons-nous dans
ce débat sans faux semblant et sans
posture politique un appel au compromis
entre la majorité sénatorial qui incarne
la volonté d'une réforme et la majorité
présidentielle qui porte la
responsabilité de la réforme un appel à
la cohérence la majorité sénatoriale a
tant voulu cette réforme et la voté de
nombreuses fois
un appel à la responsabilité augmenter
les impôts pour financer les retraites
ce n'est pas la bonne solution car à la
fin il y en a toujours un qui paye et
celui-ci s'appelle le contribuable
[Musique]